There are several questions,
the essential questions that leaders and
managers should ask themselves when they
look at how they want kpis to have an
impact and influence on their
organizations.
The most important one is obvious.
What's most important to the
organization?
Where is value really created?
Where is value really created for us
internally and for our clients,
for our customers,
for our users,
whether they be business or consumers.
Okay.
How do we want to measure that?
What kind of performance leads to those
kinds of outcomes?
The big challenge,
the difficult challenge.
The challenge that my colleagues and I
and my clients and I and my students and
I debate and argue the most is when our
kpis means and when our kpis ends.
Sometimes we want to have key
performance because that's what
excellent means.
We're always greeting customers with a
smile.
We're always trying to provide the
easiest,
most convenient,
the best possible user experience.
There are other times when the outcome
is really what matters the most,
which is we get a profit on this.
We get a sale for this,
what our means and ends.
Sometimes the KPI's link,
here's how we've dramatically increased
our sales.
That's fantastic.
Sales Sales Kpi,
we've outperformed our sales KPI and
expectation.
Oh,
three weeks later,
three months later,
the returns for what we've sold are
larger than ever before.
The customer satisfaction scores or the
net promoter scores have dropped
precipitously.
Oh my gosh.
We have to manage trade offs between
Kpis.
The leadership challenge,
the management challenge is not just how
do we do a better job of identifying,
cultivating,
deploying kpis.
It's how do we identify and manage the
tensions and sometimes conflicts between
them.
Again,
that's why this is such a fun subject
because sometimes there can be changes
where the kpis converge or a new KPI
emerges from your observation of means
and ends.
Many stories and anecdotes that can be
told about kpis that really positively
and constructively transform how an
organization behaves and they're also
sadly,
but obviously examples of what one might
call pathological kpis.
Kpis that make sense in the moment,
but when you review their ultimate
impact internally and externally,
bad,
bad.
A classic example from 10,
15 years ago,
back when we had call centers instead of
contact centers was time spent on calls
that many call centers were compensated.
The key performance indicator was how do
we keep the call down to two minutes,
three minutes,
five minutes,
and so throughput calls per hour,
calls per day where the d a dominant Kpi
because that's what productivity was
going to be.
What did you end up with?
High throughput,
very unhappy customers.
Even oftentimes if their situation was
resolved because the feedback was I felt
rushed,
I felt they were interrupting a lot.
It was a bad ux.
It was a bad customer experience.
There was also emerging at that time the
notion of first touch,
first call resolution,
how can we get things resolved at that
time?
Uh,
the first part without making the person
called back or without your calling the
back.
Interestingly,
if I may digress,
do you know what really transformed that
KPI was chat programs?
Because what people could do was they
could do a chat to,
hey,
I'm having this kind of problem.
What should I do with this person?
And just look,
and they were able to use their
colleagues or a database or a Wiki to
get an answer to do first call
resolution.
So this ties into the notion of not just
a dominant KPI,
but how do we get a productive tension
between kpis.
One is time spent on call,
the second is effective resolution,
and the third is customer satisfied.
You're never going to get them all
right,
but there's going to be a sweet spot
there.
And in this case,
triangulating those kpis to create a
sweet spot was transformative for a lot
of call centers that subsequently became
contact centers.
So remember,
if you pick the wrong dominant KPI,
you may end up with perverse outcomes
because you are incenting perverse
behaviors.
If you'll forgive me for making a bad
acronym pun,
one of the ways you shock people into
this recognition is that you say Kpi
doesn't just stand for key performance
indicator.
It stands for key performance incentive.
So make sure you're recognizing and
rewarding the right things,
not things that can lead to perverse or
counterproductive outcomes.